moscú abandonó su principal bastión en
el noreste de ucrania el ejército ruso
informó haber ordenado a sus tropas
retirarse de las zonas de valaquía y
helium cerca de jarquil para mandarles
más al sur a reforzar los esfuerzos
militares en la región de donges una de
las zonas separatistas prorrusas
con el fin de alcanzar los objetivos
declarados de la operación militar
especial para liberar el donbass a ver
si este huesca se ha decidido reagrupar
las tropas rusas situadas en los
distritos de valaquía es uno de ellos
como problema el anuncio se produjo unas
horas después de que las tropas
ucranianas tomaron la ciudad de kut
jones que el único centro ferroviario
que abastece a toda la línea del frente
ruso en el noreste de ucrania ucrania
continúa su contraofensiva en jarc y ven
cuyos alrededores el ejército aseguró
haber recuperado el control de más de 30
asentamientos ocupados por soldados
rusos como lo muestra la parte de azul
en este mapa
el movimiento de nuestros soldados en
las diferentes direcciones del frente
continúa actualmente se han liberado
unos dos mil kilómetros cuadrados de
nuestro territorio en operaciones
activas desde principios de septiembre
en otras noticias de la jornada del
sábado los presidentes de francia y
ucrania y mayor makoun y volodymyr
selenski insistieron en que se garantice
la seguridad de la central nuclear
ucraniana de saprissa y en el plano
diplomático la ministra de exteriores
alemana anna-lena ba airbox llegó a kiev
en una visita no anunciada a los
desminadores